vielen dank herr mainz meine damen und
herren mein name ist friedrich merz mit
anders als in ihrer einladung bekommen
haben
es ist in der tat lange her dass ich das
letzte mal war die ereignisse dieser
woche wir sind etwas aus und sie haben
alle mitbekommen dass ich gestern
erklärt habe dass ich mich für den
vorsitz der cdu deutschlands bewerbe und
dass ich am achten dezember auf dem
hamburger parteitag der cdu zur
verfügung stehe als parteivorsitzender
die cdu braucht jetzt aufbruch und
erneuerung
die cdu braucht eine nach vorn
gerichtete politische diskussion und das
bedeutet aus meiner sicht
die cdu muss sich klarheit verschaffen
über ihren markenkern
wir müssen deutlich machen dass diese
partei eine große volkspartei der mitte
ist und doch bleibt und eine partei in
der liberale wertkonservative und
diejenigen die sich sozial politisch
engagieren genauso und nebeneinander
ihren platz haben eine partei aber auch
die sich um den zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft bemüht eine partei die
dafür kämpft und die gleichzeitig auch
für eine gesunde und lebenswerte umwelt
eintritt und eine partei in der ag eine
sichere zukunft für die junge generation
vor allem für unsere kinder und für
unsere enkelkinder haben wollen ich will
das auch hier ganz deutlich sagen nicht
beschwert dass und deswegen sage ich es
so deutlich wir dürfen nicht hinnehmen
dass sich am linken und rechten rand
unserer demokratie parteien in den
landtagen mittlerweile in allen 16
landtagen und auch im deutschen
bundestag etablieren
die unsere gesellschaft spalten wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass sich
wählerinnen und wähler
aus frust und enttäuschung über die
etablierten parteien solchen
populistischen bewegungen anschließen
und sich von ihren verführen lassen
hier hilft allerdings auch keine wähler
beschimpfung sondern hier hilft nach
meiner festen überzeugung ein klares
politisches profil und die helfen
politische lösungen die allen menschen
der politischen mitte eine verlässliche
heimat geben das muss der anspruch der
christlich demokratischen union
deutschlands als volkspartei der mitte
sein
und genau dafür kandidieren
angela merkel verdient
aus meiner sicht wirklich großen respekt
und anerkennung für ihre leistungen in
18 jahren an der spitze der partei
was wird sie nicht überraschen ist kein
geheimnis ich bin nicht mit allen
entscheidungen einverstanden gewesen
aber sie verdient trotzdem respekt und
anerkennung
und sie hat ganz sicher am letzten
wochenende eine schwierige ich finde
aber auch richtige entscheidung
getroffen
selbst diese erneuerung anzustoßen indem
sie den vorsitz unserer partei im
dezember abgeben wird
so wird der weg frei für eine
inhaltliche und personelle erneuerung
unserer partei und dafür brauchen wir
erfahrene aber wir brauchen auch jüngere
führungspersönlichkeiten fähige frauen
männer aus allen teilen unseres landes
ich freue mich auf eine lebendige
diskussion in der cdu in den kommenden
wochen ich will auch dass hier klar
sagen ich bin im gespräch mit einem
kampf kam bauer und die entspannen und
wir haben über das verfahren und auch
über das miteinander gesprochen
wir gehen alle drei davon aus dass wir
einen für die cdu belebende und
lebhaften streit miteinander austragen
aber fair und anständig auch in
verschiedenen formaten
darüber ist noch nicht endgültig
entschieden worden aber ich kann mir aus
meiner sicht vorstellen dass wir uns auf
regionalkonferenzen den mitgliedern der
partei
und auch die diskussion mit ihren ihnen
führen unabhängig vom verfahren wollen
wir die partei von innen heraus beleben
und den innerparteilichen demokratischen
wettbewerb auch transparent sichtbar
waren ich gehe diesen weg mit dem
notwendigen respekt vor den leistungen
unserer partei aber auch mit respekt vor
der größe der aufgabe dieses amtes
gleichzeitig die volksparteien haben in
den letzten jahren substanzielle
niederlage erlitten
sie sind zutiefst verunsichert und
brauchen eine neue orientierung
unsere mitglieder die mitglieder der cdu
unsere wählerinnen und wähler erwarten
so empfinde ich es einen klaren kurs in
einer zeit radikale umbrüche migration
globalisierung klimawandel
digitalisierung das sind aus meiner
sicht die größten herausforderungen
unserer zeit
dafür will ich den aufbruch und die
erneuerung in unserer partei anstoßen
ihn auch mit ruhiger hand führen
wir müssen genau zu wir müssen verstehen
was die menschen im land bewegt und wir
dürfen sie nicht mit floskeln abspeisen
am ende müssen wir dann aber auch zu
klaren entscheidungen kommen meine damen
und herren sie wissen dass ich bin in
den letzten zehn jahren nicht in der
aktiven politik gewesen
ich war fünf jahre mitglied des
europäischen parlaments 15 jahre
mitglied des deutschen bundestages und
bin im jahre 2009 aus freien stücken aus
dem deutschen bundestag ausgeschieden
und habe mich wieder meinem beruf
zugewandt ich habe diese knapp zehn
jahre allerdings auch gelegenheit gehabt
die politik ein wenig von außen zu
betrachten sozusagen einen blick von
außen auch auf die politik und ihre
entscheidungen zu werfen ich habe in
meinem beruf im inland und im ausland
gearbeitet ich möchte auch diese meine
beruflichen erfahrungen auf
internationaler und auf nationaler ebene
einbringen in die erneuerung unserer
partei ich habe schon gesagt wir
brauchen aufbruch und erneuerung aber
wir brauchen keinen umsturz die
grundwerte an denen sich die christlich
demokratische union deutschlands
orientiert sind immer noch die richtige
aber ihre notwendige auslegung hat sich
grundlegend verändert
die öffnung und modernisierung unserer
partei muss vorangetrieben werden
wir brauchen auch deutlich mehr frauen
und vor allem mehr junge menschen in
unseren gremien und in der gesamten
partei und die modernisierung unserer
partei muss ein schließen dass gerade in
zeiten von migration und globalisierung
nationale identität und traditionelle
werte einen festen platz in unserem
denken und handeln
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass dies
ein lebensgefühl auch widerspiegelt
übrigens ein lebensgefühl in den großen
städten auch den universitätsstädten das
zunehmend die grünen übernommen haben
und dass nicht mehr die cdu hat und lädt
das ließ ein lebensgefühl widerspiegelt
nachdem sich viele menschen in unserer
gesellschaft wirklich sehen und lassen
sie mich dies auch hinzufügen
diese werte sind ein attraktives angebot
für die jungen in unserem land denn wir
brauchen wieder die jungen in der
politik für die politik und die sich für
die politik auch interessiert ich werde
mich dafür einsetzen dass sie wieder für
politik begeistert werden unsere politik
darf daher auch nicht zu lasten der
jungen generation gehen
sie müssen vielmehr ihre eigenen
interessen einbringen investieren und
wir müssen hier alle zusammen mehr
aufmerksamkeit schenken
meine damen damen und herren
abschließend zu meiner person vor ihnen
steht ein wirklich überzeugte europäer
ein überzeugter transatlantik in diesem
sinne trete ich ein für ein weltoffenes
deutschland dessen wurzeln in der
christlichen ethik und der europäischen
aufklärung liegen und dessen wichtigste
politische verbündete die demokratien
des westens sind ja ich verwende diesen
ausdruck wieder und auch gern die
demokratien des westens
ich bin bereit dafür verantwortung in
unserer partei zu übernehmen und ich
handeln dabei auch aus persönlicher
leidenschaft aus freude an der
politischen arbeit aus überzeugung an
dem was uns verbindet aber auch aus der
überzeugung heraus dass wir etwas
gestalten können und dass wir gemeinsam
mit der cdu deutschlands einen beitrag
leisten um unsere gesellschaft ihrem
inneren zusammenhalt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zu starten
und das ist sozusagen meine motivation
warum ich am achten dezember für dieses
amt das amt des vorsitzenden der
christlich demokratischen union
deutschlands in hamburg kandidierte hast
du dann dazu einige fragen frau geschäft
hält an
märz wenn ich ihn hier schafft vom zdf
hauptstadtstudio ich wüsste gerne warum
sie jetzt antreten und nicht bei den
vergangenen parteitagen angetreten sind
haben sie sich dagegen angela merkel
nicht getraut und sie haben in ihrer
ausführung jetzt nicht das wort
versöhnung benutzt was werden sie tun
wenn sie denn gewählt werden damit sie
nicht der neue horst seehofer angela
merkels seite werden
hitzkopf das letzte schließlich
vollkommen aus
zu versöhnen gibt es zwischen angela
merkel und mir nichts wir haben uns in
den letzten jahren häufiger getroffen
unterhalten gut verstanden miteinander
meine entscheidung geht zurück auf das
jahr 2002 und im jahr 2002 war es für
mich klar dass der fraktionsvorsitz und
der parteivorsitz in einer hand gehören
die umstände dieser entscheidung haben
wir damals nicht gefallen aber die
entscheidung als solche war richtig so
und deswegen war es für mich auch klar
dass ich nach einer gewissen zeit auch
wieder zurück in meinem beruf gehe
übrigens das ist etwas völlig
undramatisch
es gibt es im privatleben der ein oder
andere von kent von ihnen kennt es auch
das gibt es im berufsleben
es gibt sogar in der politik es gibt
menschen die einfach ja von ihren
überzeugungen oder auch von ihrer art
wie sie arbeiten nicht zusammenpassen
und dann muss man auseinander gehen und
das ist noch mal ist es für mich auch
undramatisch gewesen zur entscheidung
2009 vorstand danke schön heute chef der
bild am sonntag herr merz haben gerade
beschrieben dass sie in den letzten
jahren ja wie politik beziehungsweise
die auch die partei eher von der
außenperspektive beobachtet haben wie
wollen sie denn jetzt in der kürze der
zeit die mitglieder bzw die delegierten
davon überzeugen dass sie der richtige
mann für sie sind na ja von außen
beobachten heißt ja nicht dass man nur
außen steht
ich habe ja nun nach wie vor viel
kontakte zu vielen mandatsträgern in der
cdu ich bin seit 1973 ununterbrochen
mitglied dieser partei
also ich glaube unverändert ich verstehe
diese partei und ich kenne diese partei
ich habe aber immer gesagt und der eine
oder andere von ihnen weiß dass das ich
der meinung bin dass wir einen häufigen
wechsel zwischen beruf und politik
brauchen könnten
ich habe das für mich immer gelten
lassen und das gilt auch jetzt in beide
richtungen man kann auch mal eine zeit
außerhalb der politik verbringen und
zeigen ob die eigenen überzeugungen und
das was man kann auch an anderer stelle
erfolg haben und kann dann wieder in die
politik zurück gehen ich sehe das in
amerika sehr häufig ich sehe es in
deutschland zu selten so und deswegen
habe ich da großes selbstvertrauen dass
das gelingt er gefällt
märz wie soll denn zusammenarbeit
zwischen dem parteivorsitzenden märz und
der bundeskanzlerin gelingen bis 2021
wird sie gar nicht so lange halten und
haben sie schon gelegenheit gefunden die
tätigkeiten ihres früheren arbeitgebers
blackrock daraufhin zu überprüfen ob er
für ihre politischen gegner nicht
möglicherweise verletzungs potenzial
bietet ja ich habe mit dem letzten an
ich habe das natürlich mit dem
vorstandsvorsitzenden von blackrock
gesprochen
er weiß das
ich will nur darauf hinweisen ich
beabsichtige diese firma in deutschland
aber ich führe sie nicht die kollegen
dort bedauern dass ausdrücklich dass ich
möglicherweise nicht mehr ihr
aufsichtsratsvorsitzender sein werde
aber ich bin übrigens dankbar dafür dass
die meisten jedenfalls in der
beschreibung dieser firma auch richtig
darauf hingewiesen haben dass ist keine
heuschrecke das ist kein private equity
das ist ein vermögensverwalter
ja der größte auf der welt aber
vermögensverwalter sind treuhänder der
einlagen ihrer kunden und insofern fühle
ich mich da ausgesprochen wohl mit diese
firma verwaltet das vermögen von
hunderttausenden privater kunden
treuhänderisch und sie vertrauen uns das
geld an
und deswegen ist das aus meiner sicht
keinerlei konfliktlage was die
zusammenarbeit mit der bundeskanzlerin
betrifft will ich gerne bezug nehmen auf
das was sie am montag gesagt hat sie hat
ja selbst gesagt dass sie da ihre
bisherige auffassung korrigiert hat und
dass sie das wagnis sieht in der
trennung von parteivorsitz und amt des
bundeskanzlers
ich kann aus meiner sicht nur sagen ich
bin bereit mich auf dieses wagnis
einzulassen
herr jung im märz sie hatten die jungen
leute angesprochen viele junge leute
kennen sie in deutschland gar nicht mehr
also mir fällt auch noch ein dass sie
mal eine steuererklärung auf dem
bierdeckel machen wollten dass sie hat
viel für mit 132 euro für ausreichend
gehalten haben und dass sie jetzt in den
letzten jahren für die für das größte
finanzinstitut der welt gearbeitet haben
was müssen junge leute die jetzt sie zum
ersten mal sehen über sie wissen und sie
stehen ja auch für eine neoliberale
richtung in ihrer partei der
neoliberalismus ist ja eine ein grund
der spaltung in unserer gesellschaft wie
wollen sie dann die gesellschaft und
auch ihre partei zusammen können also
zunächst einmal dieses zitat mit den
hartz-iv-sätzen stimmt nicht dafür gibt
es auch keinen beleg bis falsch 2 ich
habe mich nie als neoliberaler empfunden
das ist ein politischer kampfbegriff
geworden
anders als ursprünglich mal von denen
die den liberalismus in deutschland
formuliert haben gedacht war und
deswegen habe ich mich von diesem
begriff auch immer distanziert
ich bin von meiner ganzen überzeugung
und neigung her ein wirtschaftsliberaler
ein wertkonservativer und ein sozial
politisch engagierter mensch und das hat
die cdu auch immer stark gemacht dass
sie in der lage war diese strömungen
miteinander zu verbinden und ich habe
mich im grunde genommen allen teilen in
gleichem maße verbunden gefühlt war
allerdings auch immer der überzeugung
dass ein sozialstaat nur das ausgeben
kann das eine wirtschaftsnationen oder
eine volkswirtschaft auch in der lage
ist zu verdienen an der an der
überzeugung ändert sich bei mir auch in
zukunft nichts dass wir trotzdem große
herausforderungen haben dass sie eine
gespaltene gesellschaft haben übrigens
wenn wir mal aus in einigen jahren
zurückblicken werden auf die folgen der
finanzkrise
die finanzkrise wird die spaltung noch
weiter vertieft haben insbesondere wegen
der not sind politik der zentralbanken
die folgen die können wir heute erst
ahnen die werden wir erst in einigen
jahren wirklich verstehen ich bin schon
der auffassung dass wir grundsätzlich
über die frage bis hin zu der frage wie
beteiligen wir eigentlich eine größere
zahl von privaten haushalten an den
kapitalmärkten dass wir über diese frage
reden müssen deutschland hat eine viel
zu kleine zahl von aktionären
andere länder sind da viel weiter als
wir und ich möchte auch dazu einen
beitrag leisten dass wir weiterkommen
naja und die müssen sie die jungen
menschen also ich kann das so nicht
feststellen natürlich ist es so ich bin
vor zehn jahren aus der aktiven politik
ausgeschieden also diejenigen die heute
20 sind waren damals 10
dass mich die 20-jährigen mich mehr
kennen das weiß ich aber die 30 jährigen
wissen sich gut zu erinnern und die
anderen werden wir auch gehen lernen
rinke herzlich ganz gerne nochmal nach
noch mal nachgefragt bei dem wagnis was
sie hin angesprochen hatten
der zusammenarbeit mit der kanzlerin
gehen sie davon aus dass das mit der
kanzlerin und ihnen als parteichef bis
2021 funktionieren kann zum einen und
zweitens bei europa sie haben sich als
pro europäer geben bezeichnet was
konkret heißt das sind sie bei den
ganzen eurozonen reformen eher auf der
seite von emanuel makro und sagen wir
müssen viel weiter vorangehen mit
punkten die auch in der
bundestagsfraktion der union durchaus
umstritten sind oder raten sie dazu
vorsicht ich bin der festen überzeugung
dass angela merkel und ich miteinander
unter diesen veränderten bedingungen
auskommen und klar kommen werden und
zwar so wie wir beide es dann gemeinsam
vorteil
ich bin in der tat besorgt darüber dass
wir zu wenig antwort haben auf die
vorschläge von emanuel makro ich finde
dass er mehr verdient hat auch an
wirklich an substanzieller antwort aus
deutschland übrigens das gilt auch für
das weitgehend unbekannt gebliebene
weißbuch der eu kommission zur zukunft
der europäischen union
dass als folge des exit votums der
briten im letzten frühjahr herausgegeben
worden ist mit fünf verschiedenen
vorschlägen wie sich die europäische
union denn entwickeln soll
und darauf hat es praktisch aus den
mitgliedstaaten keine antwort gegeben
wir müssen über diese zentralen fragen
der zukunft der europäischen union
sprechen und ich weiß dass das größte
die größte herausforderung darin besteht
die euro zone zusammenzuhalten
das wird für die nächsten jahre die
größte herausforderung europas werden
und ich habe dazu meinungen aber lassen
sie mal heute dieses kurz vor markt der
bundespressekonferenz
so stehen wie es steht ich werde dazu
auch mich noch sehr dezidiert äußern
dann kommen der mit herrn holz für heute
zur letzten frage
märz wenn sie sagen sie sind bereit
dieses wagnis einzugehen hört sich das
so an als ob sie auch nicht als ob sie
auch davon überzeugt werden das
kanzleramt und parteivorsitz im grunde
in einer hand gehören ist das so und wie
gedenken sie ihr amt als cdu chef
auszuüben machen sie das künftig
hauptberuflich sozusagen so als einen
dollar mann und haben sie da sie haben
ja keine möglichkeit im parlament zu
sprechen sich im kabinett zu wort zu
melden
wie wollen sie das ausgleichen strich
konnte sich nach ja ja ich konzentriere
mich jetzt auf den achten dezember und
auf die diskussion in der partei mit der
partei und über die partei und wenn die
entscheidung gemacht
dezember getroffen ist werden wir reden
und alles weitere dann auch gemeinsam
entscheiden und dann haben wir
mindestens 21 weitere wortmeldungen wenn
du dann mal
[Musik]
ja meine damen und herren das war also
friedrich merz hier in einer kurz
pressekonferenz schade man hätte
sicherlich noch viel mehr fragen gerne
an ihn gestellt er hat gesagt wir
brauchen aufbruch und erneuerung und
keinen umsturz und hat sich mühe gegeben
in dieser kurzen zeit immer wieder
mantraartig darzustellen dass er mit
angela merkel gut auskommen wird wenn er
parteichef ist und sie weiter kanzlerin
er hat auch gesagt dass er die
entscheidung im jahr 2002 zwar verärgert
war aber immer eingesehen habe dass der
parteivorsitz den damals ja angela
merkel in hatte und der fraktionsvorsitz
in einer hand gehört ehrlich gesagt ich
habe die zeit damals begleitet das war
nicht ganz so damals hatte das überhaupt
nicht verstanden hat aber aus seiner
sicht auch ein vorspiel gehabt denn er
hatte die feste zusage vor allen dingen
von edmund stoiber das egal wie die wahl
ausgeht er fraktionsvorsitzender bleibt
und über stinksauer
auch auf die cdu chefin dass die sich
damals das recht herausgenommen hat nach
der verlorenen bundestagswahl eben nicht
in einem kabinett stoller einzutreten
sondern das konnte sie ja dann auch
nicht sondern fraktionsvorsitzende wurde
aber da hat friedrich merz vielleicht
den mantel der geschichte ein bisschen
drüber gedeckt insgesamt fiel auf am
anfang war friedrich merz ein bisschen
nervös ungewohnt für ihn aber er ist ja
hier großen foren jahr im
wirtschaftsbereich gewohnt hier vor der
bundespressekonferenz
da hat der eine oder andere im am anfang
doch ein bisschen davon vielleicht hat
sich dann gut gefangen hat seine
position hier klar gemacht hat auch noch
einmal erklärt dass er mit den beiden
anderen kandidaten annegret kramp
karrenbauer und jens spahn bereits
gesprochen hat und dass man
offensichtlich alle drei wollen
regionalkonferenzen durch die cdu
tingeln und sich da noch einmal
vorstellen damit die delegierten 1001
beim parteitag im dezember auch eine
wahl zwischen diesen dreien dann auch
treffen können es werden sicherlich noch
zwei drei andere dazu kommen diese
unbekannten kandidaten sich schon
gemeldet haben denen man keine chancen
einräumt einer wird nicht mehr mitmachen
und das ist der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident armin laschet er hat
hier vor wenigen minuten verkündet in
den agenturen
er steht momentan nicht zur verfügung
das war zu erwarten
man muss dazu sagen armin laschet hat
mit allen beteiligten gesprochen so wie
er das angekündigt hat hat sich dann die
chancen ausgerechnet im übrigen eher und
friedrich merz können persönlich sehr
gut miteinander
ich hatte mir von anfang an auch immer
schon gedacht dass sie nicht
gegeneinander kandidieren werden
wenngleich sie so ein bisschen in einem
anderen lager in der cdu stehen aber das
wird nicht der hauptgrund gewesen sein
sondern der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident und stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende weiß sehr wohl dass in
nordrhein westfalen viel arbeit auf ihn
wartet und wenn man mal an den einen
oder anderen parteivorsitzenden der spd
da gab es ja genug schaut der
ministerpräsident war und gleichzeitig
hier in berlin seine partei organisieren
sollte dann ist das wahrscheinlich eine
gute entscheidung dass man nicht aus dem
fernen düsseldorf auch die cdu lenken
kann da braucht man viel zu viel zeit
hier in berlin
und das hat armin laschet offensichtlich
dann heute mitgeteilt also es werden
diese drei prominenten kandidaten
zunächst bleiben es gibt ja noch den
einen oder anderen der könnte auch
seinen hut in den ring werfen das bleibt
abzuwarten
jedenfalls hat friedrich merz hier seine
position klar gemacht er sagt wir
brauchen einen aufbruch
wir müssen den menschen mehr zuhören und
wir wollen die ränder wieder abschmelzen
das ist das credo von friedrich merz und
viele trauen ihm das auch zu dass er die
konservative seele der cdu streichelt
und in der tat zum beispiel der afg
wähler abjagen kann einziges problem für
märz und den wirtschaftsflügel der sich
gleich mal hinter ihm versammelt hat
jens spahn ist ja auch noch daher steht
eigentlich in einem ähnlichen oder
gleichen flügel ist ein junger mann mit
38 friedrich merz wird in wenigen tagen
also das kann sehr gut also ausgehen
dass die beiden sich die stimmen auf dem
parteitag nehmen und andreas kramp
karrenbauer sie hat ohnehin die nase in
dem rennen doch ziemlich weit vorne seit
einem halben jahr generalsekretären
tourt sie durch die partei bereitet ein
neues grundsatzprogramm vor und hat die
parteigliederung bereist schon seit 1
ja und ist sehr sehr nah an der cdu also
es dürfte spannend werden dass wir auch
noch nicht das letzte wort hier
es wird sicherlich weiter diskutiert
werden die nächsten tage und wochen die
frage ob die anderen kandidaten sich
öffentlich vorstellen
die hörig allenthalben müssen sie ja
eigentlich nicht denn sie sind ja nun
wirklich bekannt annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat ja jeden montag die
chance bei den pressekonferenzen zur
deutsche öffentlichkeit zu sprechen und
jens spahn der heute in der
pressekonferenz allerdings nur zu sagen
gesundheitsposten was gesagt hat ist
auch bekannt und muss ich eigentlich so
vorstellen wie friedrich merz der gesagt
hat na gut die leute die jetzt 20 sind
die kennen mich nicht mehr aber spielt
dieses die 30 sind die kennen mich noch
härteren von follower vielen dank für
die einschätzung nach dieser
pressekonferenz danke ihnen nach berlin